Okay,
well last time we looked at the early
tutors reestablishing the authority of the
monarchy and now we turn towards what
was to prove one of the biggest problems
for most of the 16th century.
The question of the authority of the
church and of the nature of English
religion.
Um,
let's start by taking you
to a couple of places.
A few miles north of the city of
Cambridge in the Fed lands the flatlands
stretching up to towards the sea.
Uh,
there lies the small city of Ely,
which has one of the greatest
of English cathedrals in it.
Um,
Eley Cathedral dates
back to the 12th century.
And,
uh,
when you go there,
um,
the main nave of the Cathedral is
a magnificent Norman architecture,
uh,
but rather gloomy.
Um,
but at the bottom of the name there's a
little door which leads through to the
lady chapel.
And if you go through there,
you get struck almost
immediately by dazzling light.
You find yourself in a beautiful chapel,
late medieval chapel with vast windows
glazed in clear glass with the light
streaming through on a sunny day.
It's quite an astonishing contrast.
And it's only when your eyes get used to
light that you notice that in the stone
tracery of the windows,
there are niches where once statues stood,
some of them are still there with the
heads broken off for half the status.
You still there and here and there
in the white glass in the windows,
uh,
you see a little bit of stained glass
that they found and replaced in what were
once windows full of
stained glass pictures.
So that's Ely cathedral.
If we go a couple of hundred
miles north to North Yorkshire,
there's a little church there
called Saint Agatha's ease be,
it lies by the river,
not far from the town of Richmond,
which I was talking about last week.
Uh,
and at DSP there's a
tiny 12th century church,
Saint Agatha's.
Um,
the windows are very small.
and when you go in it's exceedingly dim.
But again,
when your eyes adjust to the light,
you notice on the walls
faded war paintings,
which were probably put there
sometime early in the 13th century.
Um,
there's Adam and eve.
Uh,
there's the Nativity,
very nice nativity scene
with a very sweet donkey.
Uh,
and so the story continues
around the walls,
through the crucifixion
and the resurrection.
Um,
and in the spaces left
by the main paintings,
uh,
they're are little portrayals
of medieval peasants at work,
sewing,
plowing and so forth
and outside by the river
are the ruins of ease,
be happy,
which was quite near the
Church of Saint Agatha's.
Okay,
well we can use those two places to
symbolize the way that the Protestant
reformation has been presented in the
historiography of early modern England.
To some people it was,
as it were,
a flood of light
purifying,
racing,
invigorating,
liberating.
On the other hand,
other historians have greatest sympathy
for the religious culture represented by
those faded wall paintings in the church
at ECSB or the empty niches in the
windows at Ely cathedral or the ruined
monastery by the river east be Abby.
They have a greater sense of what was
lost of the destruction of a great deal of
beauty in the course of the
zeal of the reformation.
Well prior to the 1980s
one could say in general,
it was the first approach,
which tended to be the dominant tradition.
The reformation was generally
seen as being positive.
As Christopher Marshall puts it,
it had purpose and direction and
even a certain inevitability.
Nowadays,
the dominant trend is rather
in the other direction,
it tends to stress the destruction
of the older religious tradition.
A destruction,
which to quote marshe
again was regrettable,
undesired and undesirable.
So as a result,
we now have a much more two dimensional
historiography of the reformation.
And that's a good thing.
A history should involve
critical examination rather
than mere celebration or
self congratulation.
But if we have a more
two dimensional picture,
one which includes not only
the reformers and the victors,
but also those who resisted
and those who lost,
it's still not exactly even handed.
Historians inevitably
have their preferences.
They tend to lean one way or the other.
And this whole story is one which
still engages a good deal of passion.
Well,
today I want to start
approaching all of that.
Um,
by considering the nature of the old
religion and the state of the Prereq
Formation Church,
it's strengths,
it's weaknesses,
uh,
and those who were already there are
criticizing some of its features and that
will help us to begin consideration of
how it was possible in only a few years
to bring this great edifice crashing down
at the beginning of the 16th century.
The church was of course the greatest
corporate institution in the kingdom.
It was the English branch of a
great international institution,
which gave Western Europe it's identity
collectively as Catholic Christendom
the church in England,
because there wasn't a
church of England yet.
The church in England was organized
into two provinces with archbishops at
Canterbury and York.
And then there were 21 diocese,
each of them headed by a bishop.
And beneath that archdeacon
reason deaneries and so on,
down to somewhat more than 9,000
parishes at most local level,
each with its parish church.
And in addition,
scattered around the
landscape but particularly
concentrated in the parts of the
north and the West where the
great monasteries and nunneries,
uh,
some 750 of them in all
the clergy who staffed this institution.
We're a distinct est of the realm.
As you already know.
Uh,
attempts have been made
to estimate their numbers.
It's been estimated about 60,000 in all,
which would mean that the clergy
comprised about 4% of the entire national
population or since most of them were men,
something like 8% of the
entire male population,
very large presence.
Members of the clergy enjoyed a privileged
position before the law they were
dealt with in the church courts.
In the first instance though,
they could sometimes be handed over
to the secular authorities if they had
committed crimes and they were supported
by a variety of fees and dues paid to
them.
And in particular tides by which people
gave a 10th of their income or produce
for the maintenance of the church.
And then of course there was a great
endowments given to the Church by Pius
members of the Laity.
So it was a great institution,
a wealthy institution,
the owner of a great deal
of land and property,
but also a collection of more than
9,000 small Christian communities
periodically United in their parish,
churches in worship,
in the practice of their religion,
and in considering the old
religion and it's nature,
we should perhaps start there with
the fundamentals of the nature and
characteristics of the old faith.
Well,
the central doctrines
can be covered briefly.
They were as follows.
Christ's sacrifice on the cross had made
salvation available to sinful humankind
through grace.
Divine favor,
access to grace,
the means of salvation was made available
through the church and through its
sacraments.
Membership of the church was gained
through the sacrament of baptism,
usually in infancy,
of course,
and it was demonstrated by continued
participation in the sacraments,
especially the mass when elements of
bread and wine were consecrated and
transformed into the
body and blood of Christ.
Through the miracle of transubstantiation,
the Christian life involved
obedience to the 10 commandments,
avoidance of the seven deadly sins,
participation in the sacraments,
the doing of good works and prayer.
Given that all mankind was sinful,
believers will enjoy enjoined
to repent of their sins,
to confess them,
to perform penance for them.
And in return,
they were granted
absolution by the priest.
The church as a whole was conceived
of as a community of saints.
And so it was possible to
pray for the souls of others.
In addition to which the saints already
in heaven were believed to intercede
with God on behalf of living believers.
So petitionary prayers could
be addressed to saints.
And finally,
the expiation of sins committed in
life could continue after death.
When souls lingered in purgatory,
until they were purged of sin and
made fit for Heaven for heaven,
the living could ease the passage of the
dead through purgatory by their press.
Only those who fail to achieve salvation
by their rejection of the means of
grace would probably ultimately
suffer eternal torment in hell.
Okay.
Those are the basic beliefs
in its transmission of these central
beliefs and in its practices of worship.
The pre reformation church fostered
what's been described as a ritually and
visually rich religion and a society in
which the vast majority of people were
illiterate.
The decorations of the church,
the paintings on the wall,
like those in Esb,
the images,
the carved images around
the walls or the altars,
the stained glass windows
with their pictures.
All of these were to a large extent the
books of the unlearned and often they
conveyed the essence of central Bible
stories like the progression from the
garden of Eden through to
the crucifixion and so forth.
And he's B and they conveyed sometimes
the central doctrines of the faith in
visual representations.
And outstanding example of this is a
15th century stained glass window which
survives still in a church near Exeter
in the West country call at a place
called [inaudible].
They have interesting place
names in the West country.
Uh,
I haven't written it on the
board because the words too long,
but you'll find it on your handout.
Darlings can leave.
Um,
in the great window there,
they have portrayals up in seven
panels of each of the seven sacraments.
Each of those panels is also linked by
a red line in the glass to the wounds of
Christ on the cross.
And the message is quite clear.
Christ's sacrifice,
the flow of grace along the red
lines through the sacraments,
which the,
the,
the window represents the
congregation participating in,
or again,
most churches had an elaborately carved
rood screen which stood at the entrance
to the chancel where the altar was,
uh,
with wooden statues above it.
Again,
a crucifix and Various Central Saints.
Um,
all there for observation and
veneration by the congregation.
Well,
numerous other images and pictures would
adorn the side chapels of the churches.
They would be alters dedicated to
particular saints and so forth.
At indeed this devotion to the saints,
it was a particularly marked
characteristic of late
medieval popular religion.
Images and shrines and relics of the
saints were much venerated and much
visited.
Uh,
there were some very great
centers of pilgrimage.
Um,
in Canterbury Cathedral was
the shrine of Saint Thomas,
Rebecca to 12th century English.
St and Walsingham was a shrine
dedicated to the virgin.
A Durham was the shrine of Saint Cuthbert.
The Great Saxon Saint
of the north of England.
And so one could go on.
These were the great shrines,
but there were also many lesser localized
places which were visited by pilgrims
from the area round about and they would
make donations to beautify the images
at the alternate the saints
and to maintain their shrines.
For example,
down near Exeter,
again,
there was a local saint
called Saint Sidwell,
sid w,
e double l.
She was,
uh,
a Celtic Marta from the early days of
the church in Britain and record survive
of the gifts that people
made to St Sidwell.
Uh,
in Exeter.
Um,
one person gave her wedding
ring too since it will,
uh,
girdles were given to adorn the
statue rosary beads of fine quality.
We're given to be hung about the statue.
Uh,
there was money given for renewing
the gilding on since it will statue.
One person even gave money to buy
her a new pair of velvet slippers.
And in return,
people of course made petitionary
prayers to the saints.
You could borrow the girdles to
lay across a woman in childbirth,
which was thought to protect her.
Well,
obviously this was a system which
could offer a great deal of comfort,
but at the same time it could be
open to the risk of corruption.
It could obscure people's focus upon
the central doctrines of the faith and
substitute devotion to particular saints
cults and The Times Expectations of an
almost mechanical manipulation of the
powers of particular saints in response to
acts of veneration and donations.
Uh,
Erasmus of Rotterdam,
the great humanist scholar of the
early 16th century who taught at the
University of Cambridge for a while,
um,
was deeply critical of all this.
He wanted a simpler,
more Bible centered faith
and he joked in one of his,
one of his essays,
uh,
about how they were enough pieces of
the true cross or alleged pieces of the
true cross in churches in Europe
that if you've got them all together,
you could build Noah's Ark.
So Erasmus was prepared to scoff
at all of this and he wasn't alone.
There was undoubtedly a,
an accretion of superstitious practices
around these forms of devotion,
which is scrupulous churchmen like
Erasmus found very hard to take.
And some of the saints who were venerated
but rather dubious provenance all over
the country.
There were holy wells and holy trees where
people would hang gifts and offerings
and make requests for assistance.
Many of these were very dubious origins
and probably had originated as Celtic
water spirits and tree spirits,
which had been gradually incorporated
into the local practice of Christianity in
the early Middle Ages.
And then of course there was a
whole business of the relics,
the Abbey of Barry Saint Edmonds,
which lies about halfway
between Cambridge and knowledge,
had quite a collection.
They had the clippings
from Saint Edmonds nails.
They had the coals with which Saint
Lawrence had been toasted to death.
They had,
so Thomas Tank,
Thomas of Canterbury's pen knife,
and one of his boots,
all of which were objects of veneration.
Well,
a lot of this was clearly very far
from being impeccably Christian.
It was the product of
the medieval churches,
toleration of what people
refer to as syncretism.
That's the word,
the blending together of
different religious traditions,
the Christianizing of
some older traditions like
those holy wells and sacred
trees and so forth.
And at times it could undoubtedly be
hard to draw the line between where
Christian devotion to the saints ended
and superstitious practices began.
Okay.
Well the older historiography tended to
lay a lot of emphasis on that kind of
thing,
stressing the corruption and degeneracy
of the old church and the compromised
nature of it's spirituality.
But more recently in the work of
historians like JJ scares brick and Damian
Duffy and Christopher,
hey,
all of whom are on our reading lists,
there's been a tendency to point out
instead the soundness of some of the core
elements of worship and to
argue that whatever its faults,
the pre reformation religious system
was in fact hugely successful and hugely
popular,
far from being a sort of rotten tree
ready to fall before the first blast of
reforming wind.
Christopher Haigh argues that late
medieval Catholic Christianity,
to quote him,
was not only secure in
early modern England,
but also luxuriant and energetic
and the strongest arguments in favor of
such views derived from the evidence of
energetic commitment to conventional
devotions at the lowest level,
at the level of the parish.
Um,
there,
there are three major sources of
such evidence which people draw upon.
Um,
first of all,
there are people's wills.
Most of them from the early 16th
century leave some bequest to religion.
Um,
the requests,
the bequest of money for services for
the beautification of churches and so
forth.
Uh,
one of the most spectacular examples
as a man of mentioned before,
the extremely wealthy Robert
Janice of the city of Norwich who,
um,
left when he died in the 1520s,
uh,
the greater part of his
fortune for religious purposes,
you'd have to 1400 pounds in all which
I was trying to translate into modern
money.
Um,
it's difficult to do that,
but five or $6 million perhaps left to
religious purposes in modern equivalent.
And there was a particular focus in
such pious bequests upon the endowing of
prayers and masses for dead souls.
Robert Janice,
for example,
of his 1400 pounds laid down that 800
of it was to be spent on paying pre
priests to say prayers for his soul
and for all other Christian souls.
And in addition,
he provided 400 pounds,
a four masses,
which should be said for the same,
dedicated to the same purpose.
So pious bequests is one form of evidence
of this enthusiasm and involvement.
Secondly,
there are church wardens,
accounts,
the account books of parish churches which
sometimes survive and they reveal the
substantial sums of money which people
raised and spent on their churches,
on the fabric of the church,
and it's rebuilding and
beautification and on its furnishings.
They spent far more on such purposes
than they ever paid in taxes or then they
paid to them and oral lords in rents.
Thirdly,
there's the evidence of the activity of
religious guilts all over the country.
There were numerous fraternities or
gilts formed for religious purposes where
people would band together to maintain
an altar and to pray for the souls of
members of the guild,
both the living and
those who had passed on.
They also often had a
charitable functions,
poor relief and educational functions,
and they were very,
very many of these voluntary
fraternities and guilts,
which people joined in
the city of London alone.
There were 81 religious fraternities
operating in the early years of the 16th
century in Norridge in 1500.
There were 21 and even much
smaller places could have them.
The tiny parish of more bath in Devon,
which is to the north of Exeter,
was a place where they had
several guilds which would,
which were run by different
groups within the population.
It was a women's guild.
There was a young people's Guild,
um,
the peasants of the area dedicated some
of their sheep to the maintenance of
their gills and the members took
turns to look after those sheep.
Are the profits went for the
maintenance of the guilds activities?
Well,
clearly there's a lot of evidence of
such activity and such investment in
traditional religion.
It was clearly prodigious and
participation was widespread.
You can't gain say that
the evidence is clear.
It supports such views as that of the
historian Richard Rex who argues that it's
possible that the ideal of a Christian
community United in belief and worship,
an ideal which was to be
pursued so zealously by
Protestants and Catholics alike
was never so closely approximated
to as in the late medieval Paris.
It's certainly possible to read the
evidence that way and at present,
as I've said,
that's,
that's the dominant
trend in historiography,
but at the same time,
one has to recognize that it's
not without some ambiguity's.
One can't be sure quite how well attended
parish churches actually where one
can't be quite sure just how extensive
participation in parish guilds was in
some places it seems to have been quite
quite widespread though some guilds were
somewhat socially exclusive
and above all it's been said that a vast
amount of the money which was invested
in the late medieval church was invested
for the specific purpose of easing the
passage of one soul through purgatory.
That was fundamental
to a great deal of it.
As in the case of Robert
Janice and arguably that
preoccupation with easing the
passage of souls through purgatory was
motivated more by fear than by anything
else.
In a sense,
purgatory could have been a
somewhat oppressive doctrine,
raising anxiety,
particularly amongst those who couldn't
afford to pay for masters for their
souls.
In other words,
the fact of heavy investment in
traditional religion cannot be denied,
but it's meaning is
open to interpretation.
Like so much historical evidence.
You can read it more ways than one.
Well,
you can say the same sort of thing about
the evidence relating to relationships
between members of the
clergy and the Laity.
Certainly there was some
times quite acute conflict,
especially over such matters as ties.
People sometimes resent it,
the payment of ties and resisted it
or similarly other Jews which might be
demanded by the clergy.
Mortuary payments when
people died and so forth.
And then there was the perennial problem
of instances of clerical misbehavior,
especially the sexual
misconduct of a clergy was,
which was theoretically celebrate.
That was the butt of a great deal of
Ribald comment at throughout the late
medieval period.
Sometimes the jurisdiction of the church
courts which had jurisdiction over such
matters as marriage and the probate and
wills and other things which would have
a spiritual nature.
This was sometimes resented,
particularly by their rivals.
The common lawyers in the
secular courts or again,
the the pump and the pride of some of
the great clergy could occasion a certain
amount of cynicism and contempt and
outstanding example of a great clergyman.
Who attracted that kind of opprobrium?
Uh,
was Henry the eighth chief minister,
Thomas Woolsey,
Cardinal Woolsey,
who to all intents and purposes,
ran the government on Henry
the eighth behalf between 15,
14 and 1529.
Woolsey was proud.
He was arrogant.
He was extremely able,
but he was arrogant.
He held multiple livings.
He was archbishop of York.
He was bishop of Durham.
He held other church livings,
places he never visited and
do the income from them.
He engaged in a great deal
of conspicuous consumption,
building his own palaces,
most of which would
eventually confiscated by the,
he had a mistress and children
and so on and so forth.
It's been argued that if few people
envisaged an alternative religion before
1520 there was nonetheless a
good deal of anti clericalism,
which could be drawn upon when action
was eventually taken against the church.
That view clearly has some
strength and yet again,
one has to consider whether
it might be overdrawn.
It's true that the parish clergy,
what often not very well educated,
that some of them had moral failings
is that some of them came into conflict
with their parishioners,
but on the other hand,
the crucial issue was whether they
were adequate to perform the religious
services which were expected of them.
Their principal duties
were not as educators.
Their principal duties were as priests.
That principle duties was sac,
a Dota.
They had to perform the rituals,
the sacraments,
the mass.
If they had their faults,
they also had the sacred power by virtue
of the ordination to perform those
sacraments.
They had the power to consecrate
the elements in the mass.
They had the power to administer
the last rites to the dying.
They had the par to absolve sin and that
above all set them apart and it could
make them objects of
reverence or even have anxiety
in a sense.
Then human weaknesses could be
cloaked by the majesty of the office.
As for the Higher Claire g by the early
16th century men like Thomas Woolsey,
we're really spectacularly exceptional.
Most bishops on the whole,
quite an impressive group if a lot of
them were primarily administrators in
their functions and seventh of the state,
very often as well as of the church,
they were often conscientious
enough in running their diocese.
So given the powers and the
privileges of the clerical estate,
it was inevitable.
That's abuses could provoke
resentment and indeed conflict.
And there were occasional notorious
scandals which appear particularly
significant in hindsight.
Nevertheless,
if such incidents reveal tensions,
they don't necessarily reveal
a fundamental hostility
to the established church.
But there was real criticism which went
beyond mere occasion of resentment.
And it came from three sources.
First of all,
there was criticism that came from
reformers within the church itself.
Uh,
John [inaudible],
whose name is on your handout,
the Dean of St Paul's Cathedral in London,
was a man who was deeply troubled
by the failings of the church.
He is a famous sermon,
which he preached a convocation,
which was the gathering
of the Eden Clergy,
the parliament of the church,
if you'd like,
in a sermon to convocation in 1511.
He castigated the pride
and the worldliness,
which was,
was to be found among
some clergy and call.
It could be said to be representative of
the long reformers tradition within the
church itself,
whereby strict moralists demanded from
time to time that the clergy should live
up to the standards of their
own profession in a manner
which would deserve the
privileges that they enjoyed
and call it wasn't alone.
His close friend,
the pious laymen,
Thomas Moore,
a learned and devout man,
um,
sympathize greatly with college desire
for the reform of clerical standards.
And so did others among the senior clergy,
uh,
Bishop John Fisher of Rochester,
which is down in Kent or Bishop
Tunstall first of London,
then of Durham,
where other bishops who had reforming
agendas of this kind within the church.
Well,
most of these were elite critics.
They well could say,
enjoyed the luxury of,
of,
of knowing better,
but they weren't willing to challenge
the ultimate authority of the church
itself.
Nor were they really willing to damage,
um,
the practice of piety
of the common people.
They were very anxious not to break
the unity of Christian Christendom de,
they wanted the church to reform
itself and all of them died.
Catholics,
indeed Thomas Moore and John Fisher
both died as martyrs for the old faith
executed in the early years of the
reformation by Henry the eighth.
They died in defense of the papal
authority over the English church.
So there were some
critics within the church.
The other end of the scale,
there were a set of very
trenchant plebeian critics
of both church authority and
the conventional nature of
late Medieval Catholicism.
And these were the heretics known
in England as the law lords.
Yeah.
Lola,
where the followers of a 14th
century Oxford theologian,
John Wycliffe,
who had been very critical of the church
off his time with cliff had died in
1384 but his ideas survived him.
The lords where an underground heretical
sect and they had survived for over a
century.
Despite intermittent persecution.
They were deeply hostile to the
privileges enjoyed by the church.
Many of them saw both the pope and the
church hierarchy as being a kind of
collective representation of antichrist.
Uh,
they were deeply hostile to
veneration of the saints,
the Reverend's shown to saints
and to relics of the saints.
They regarded it as
fraudulent and idolatrous.
They were skeptical of the doctrine
of transubstantiation in the mass,
which they tended to see the community
service more as a service of remembers.
They regarded the doctrine of
purgatory as a false doctrine,
which had been late introduced into the
church and they saw the saying of masses
for souls as simply the mercenary racket
to put money into the pockets of the
priesthood.
And above all,
they relied upon the
authority of the Bible.
From the 1380s onwards,
Lorillards had translated the
new testament into English
and copies of their new
testament translation.
We're secretly circulated
amongst Lorillard groups.
Some of them are extremely beautiful.
One tends to imagine these as being
rather primitive products produced in
secret,
but some of them survive and they could
be in fact very beautifully produced,
even illuminated.
So these were the lords and all of these
features of their beliefs and attitudes
tend to make them sound
like Protel Protestants.
And so in a sense they were,
Wycliffe undoubtedly influenced the Great
Bohemian reformer of the 15th century
Yan who's of Prague and Yang horses
teachings deeply influenced Martin Luther.
So there is,
there is a connection which can be traced.
Both Catholics and Protestants were later
to see the Lord's as being for runners
of the reformation in England.
That's a view you find already
current by the 1540s and 1550s
but more recently their role
has been somewhat questioned
or at least a potential
for bringing about change.
The point usually made is that
certainly the law lords were present,
but they were not very numerous.
Well that's true.
Nevertheless,
there were some areas of concentration.
There were quite a few of them in London
hiding out in the crowd as it work.
There were some areas of the country where
their influence has spread and remain
deeply rooted.
The Tilton hills,
just to the north west of London,
it was one area where they
were well established.
Um,
there were outposts of these scattered
through the small towns of East Anglia.
We know about all of this
because occasionally bishops
would conduct a kind of,
um,
purge of lives within their diocese.
They would seek them out.
Uh,
in 15,
21,
one bishop,
uh,
conducted such a purge in the
county of Buckingham Show,
which is over here,
and he brought in over 400 large suspects.
So within a single county,
there were a fair number of these people.
They were nevertheless contained.
The church courts where we're vigilant.
There were these occasional purchase.
Occasionally a Lord was burned.
Though most of them,
when they were found tended to recant and
then quietly go back when they weren't
being observed to their private beliefs.
Occasionally though examples
were made and people were burned
over the nation as a whole.
They were a tiny minority,
but they were there and in some areas
they were quite a significant presence,
especially amongst the literate laity
of London and parts of the southeast of
England,
which scatterings of
sympathizers elsewhere.
There were even some members of the
clergy who secretly sympathized with the
lodge,
so they were able to retain a presence.
They were able to retain a
certain coherence through
their underground contacts,
and I think it's a mistake
to dismiss them entirely.
One could compare them perhaps to the
dissonance of eastern Europe in the 1970s
in 1980s who were hard put to survive
and we're in no position to overthrow the
established system,
but when on the lesser corrosive presence
within it and when the structures of
power where eventually to be
shaken the [inaudible] similarly,
we're ready to come out into the open
when they had the opportunity and many did
well between the critics
within the church,
the reforming members of the higher clergy
and the lodge at the other end of the
scale,
there were small numbers of people who
can be legitimately described as early
Protestants.
Most of them didn't actually
owe much to the Lord tradition.
They were mostly highly educated.
In fact,
they were mostly members of
England's to universities,
Oxford and Cambridge,
but in particularly Cambridge,
they were mostly men of
evangelical orientation,
very pious.
And when they learned of Martin Luther's
doc trinal protests made in Germany in
1517 they took an interest.
Luther's books were actually available
in the early years after his first
protest of 15,
17.
They weren't actually band
until the early 1520s,
so people could get hold of copies from
Germany and they were able to read them
to see what was going on.
Some of them became persuaded
of Luther's arguments.
Uh,
the Cambridge men who included Thomas
Cranmer later to be the Archbishop of
Canterbury under the Reform Church,
um,
met secretly at a tavern known
as the White Horse Tavern,
uh,
which was in the red light district of
the town near the river still stands.
It's now the Cambridge I folk museum.
Uh,
and the meetings amongst them were known
as little Germany because they were
discussing books which had been
smuggled from the centers of the early
reformation in Germany.
They also discussed the works
of the early Swiss reformers,
which were available to them.
Well,
the position of these early
Protestants was often rather ambiguous.
Not all of them had made a full
transition to dock trinal heresy.
Uh,
one who was much venerated later.
it was a man named
Thomas Bill [inaudible],
who was actually captured and
burned at the stake in 1531.
It seems unlikely that bill nee
was ever a full blown Lutheran.
Nonetheless,
he was a passionate evangelical who
detested some aspects of the practice of
worship.
Uh,
at the time,
uh,
he saw it as a cluttered form of devotion.
He wanted a much more biblically
based religion and he preached openly,
uh,
these beliefs,
um,
in his own words,
he went up to Jerusalem for those beliefs
and was eventually burned in the city
of knowledge
building was a sort of Protestant.
One could say he was halfway there.
Or another example is William Tyndale.
Tyndale was the f the first translator
other than the Lords of the New Testament
into English.
The translator of the first published
version of the English New Testament.
He had long had the idea that it was
desirable to translate the scriptures into
English.
But he originally brought that
project to Cuthbert Tunstall,
the reforming bishop of London.
Uh,
he was willing to do it within the
boundaries of the existing church.
Tunstall however,
would not back him.
Tunstall,
like many churchmen associated the
scriptures in English with Lalande.
He thought it was dangerous,
so Tyndall had to look
for support elsewhere.
And when rejected,
he found patronage from a
London merchant called Humphrey.
Monmouth Humphrey.
Monmouth is known to have
been a odd sympathizer.
He sent Tyndall abroad where Tyndale
eventually became a Lutheran and in 1526
produced his new testament in Germany,
had it printed there and copies were
subsequently smuggled into England through
the cloth trade with the Netherlands.
The fact that these early Protestants
were mostly based in Cambridge and parts
of East Anglia in London is no accident.
These are the areas most easily reached
by the trade routes from the Netherlands
and Germany.
Well,
as William Tyndale story indicates,
people like him had a rather
separate origin from the lol ards,
but not infrequently.
They eventually linked up with them.
The older Lord Networks was sometimes
activated to smuggle new testaments into
England and look Lutheran books into
England once they were banned and by the
1520s the two movements had to a large
extent overlapped to some extent.
They were merging together and
becoming worn a critical underground.
So one can say that England
had a religious underground
by the 1520s it did not
in itself mount a significant challenge
to the hegemony of traditional religion.
In all probability,
it would never have spontaneously gained
the strength to mount a victorious
challenge to the religious status
quo of the kind that was mounted by
Protestants in some of
the cities of Germany and
Switzerland and Flanders and so
forth.
But to say that that they might never
have gained the spontaneous strength
demands such a challenge is speculation.
Because of course what actually
happened is that this tiny minority of
dissidents,
actually one
and what made it possible was
a contingent circumstance,
a contingent circumstance of the kind
that so often makes history take turns
which are otherwise utterly unpredictable.
And that circumstance is
probably known to you.
In 1527 King Henry the eighth and man
who's hostility to Martin Luther and the
early Protestants.
Protestants was such that he had
written a book against them and had been
awarded the title defender
of the faith from the pope.
In 1521 this man decided that he
needed to have his marriage dissolved.
He was 35 his wife Catherine,
was 40 ish.
They had one daughter,
but they had no sun and the
tutors succession was in danger.
Henry needed his marriage dissolved.
He needed it desperately.
All the achievements of his father and
his own early rain in establishing the
Tudor Dynasty.
What?
At risk of being lost without
a male heir to the crown.
He needed a new wife.
He needed to remarry,
hopefully to be get such
a son to succeed him.
The pope Clement the seventh
would have loved to cooperate.
Pope's usually cooperated with
kings over such difficult matters,
but he couldn't oblige for
political reasons since the
pope was in the immediate
power of the emperor of Germany,
Charles the fifth who happened
to be clean Katherine's nephew.
So these were the contingent
circumstances and it was those contingent
circumstances,
which were to make all the difference
and how that happened.
We'll look at next week.